- hello everybody - this nano string
webinar on innate immune activation in
Alzheimer's disease my name is Micah
hanukkah and I'm working at the German
Center for neurodegenerative disease in
Bonn and as well at the Department of
neurodegenerative disease and geriatric
psychiatry of the University of Bonn so
why Alf summers we currently have about
35 million dementia cases worldwide and
expect rise to 150 million in 2050 in
Bonn in our department we see about 800
new cases per year and below you see
analysis of the past decade
of the World Health Organisation showing
that we were quite capable of dropping
mortality due various diseases including
prostate cancer heart disease stroke HIV
but at the same time we have a dramatic
rise in death from Alzheimer's disease
and that was the reason that actually
the whu-oh made dementia and alzheimerís
number one public health care issue in
2012 so we have currently no acute or
preventive therapy available and I
believe that our understanding of the
pathogenesis the genetics and the risk
factors are all critical for the
development of preventive interventional
or acute therapies for Elsa my disease
patients so this is a rough schematic
what we believe is gone on this disease
there's a precursor protein called
amyloid precursor protein AP P which is
cleaved by various secretaries in the
sequential action of beta and gamma
secretase are yelling amyloid beta
monomers of which we know best of 1 to
40 and one to forty two amino acid
length peptides and those should leave
our brain to about 25% why are the CSF
or 25% via the glymphatic system well
when they accumulate they are going to
be removed by microbial cells through
various mechanisms of degradation if
they further accumulate into oligomers
structures they
form high molecular accumulations which
ultimately deposit and so called a beta
plaques these ABA plaques are surrounded
by astrocytes and activated michael
glial cells as part of an innate immune
reaction and ultimately the neurons
showed how phosphorylation and so called
neurofibrillary tangles which are
showing dying or at least dysfunctional
neurons so what about innate immunity we
are constantly in our environment
surrounded by viruses fungi and bacteria
and what the upcoming little video will
show you is a bacteria which is going to
hunt for an innate immune cell which is
going to hunt for bacteria and you will
see that this macrophage is following
the bacteria throughout the cell culture
making a lot of clever decisions guided
by surface receptors in order to finally
hunt down the bacteria and ingested so
these innate immune system is our first
line of defense against viruses fungi
and bacteria play video
to these innate immune cells do not only
exist in the peripheral blood stream
they also exist in bernheimer organs
including the brain where we call the
microglia evidence ages in the lung
copper cells in the liver mousse and iam
cells and the kidney Bini cells in the
gut and bone marrow macrophages of
course in the in the bones now they one
of their principal action is to protect
these organs from infection but they
also contribute to organ structure and
function this is a frontal cortical
section which is stained for Congo red
and MHC test 2 positive microglia cells
and actually Congo red has been long
before it was developed or used as a
stain for human brains develop developed
for something completely different
Parvati Jie in 870 actually developed
this stain to color shirts and because
the region in Germany which that has
been developed is very rainy turned out
that this would not stay and being
washed out by rain so they put it back
onto her shelf until by accident it was
found that it also stains bacteria and
but he went to Berlin and licensed Congo
red as a bacterial stain now what is the
commonality between human brain and a
bacterial surface this came out by work
from Matthew Chapman published in
science in - - where he described with
his group that various bacteria
including Ecoline Salmonella typhimurium
or staph aureus which are all very
coming to us carry Bereshit structured
amyloids
on the surface so these big a sheet
structure amyloids are very similar to
the be - a structured amyloids which are
depositing in the brain of any patients
which can be seen here now this could
mean as a hypothesis that this myeloid
cell here
been taught by evolution of a million of
years that abolition structure is
nothing else but the pathogen and for
that reason it has been equipped by
nature with various surface receptors
collectively denoted as pattern
recognition receptors including TOS cd47
C D 36 and scavenger receptors now those
receptors are ligated there are two
principal actions one is the induction
of innate immune signaling pathways
which are leading to the production and
release of complement hackers chemokines
and cytokines and another reaction which
is a phagocytic up tag reactant in order
to clear the deborah's which has been
just generated
so
[Music]
if michael vr cells get activated these
usually high arised cells are retracting
their processes which are they're just
can the immediate environment and you
can see that the plaque residing Michael
Lee I have lost most of these processes
now next to the inflammatory reaction
which are just described there
microglial cells also start to do a lot
of sense of things including producing
BDNF and other neurotropic factors they
stop producing other stuff synaptic
scaling and they are so less efficient
in clearing the Debra's from the brain
now one early indication that this
microglial inflammatory reaction could
be of significance to our former
patients comes from a pathological work
by Joseph Rogers and others where they
showed that actually the difference
between 80 cases with the history of
dementia and patients which have a high
amyloid load in their brain which are
described as HBC's here is the number of
activated michael chiha cells at the
plaque in other words when 80 cases were
compared with high plaque normal cases
without any history of dementia the
major difference was less microglial
activation in the high plaque normal
cases now next to amyloid beta the
brains of alpha patients are bearing a
number of other and sometimes unexpected
danger associated molecular patterns and
those include for example chroma green a
which has been shown to be as effective
in inducing for example nitric oxide as
a sign of innate immune reaction when
compared to lipopolysaccharide so there
is no principal difference between an
LPS stimulus or a chroma granion a
stimulus there are
for example MRP 14 as another signal in
the brain and here you can see that MRP
14 negative mice on an AP P piece on
background produced by far left in F
alpha and interferon gamma at the same
time those microglial cells are more
effectively clearing beta amyloid in a
cell culture experiment and this type of
inflammation in humans can be visualized
by PK table 195 pet which you can see in
this ad case versus an aged non demented
control where there's only vascular
signal visible
now what is the principle effect of
inflammation on the brain first of all
there's a functional effect and we know
that cytokines including along beta
interferon gamma TNF alpha or nitric
oxide can suppress hyper camp
ATP and Hydra Cabo Campbell LTP is not
the equivalent to memory formation but
it's still an important mechanism for
information storage and consolidation
there are a lot of mechanisms of which I
just want to point out three there is
this synergism with excitotoxin city
which has been well documented by work
from Sandy hood we're in an experiment
NMDA or an inflammatory stimulus alone
was not great in inducing ADH release
and neuronal cell death
the combination of both were really
effective now there is a more recent
paper showing that Michael glial cells
can engulf synapses when there are D
chord with complement 3 in a CF 3
dependent mechanism and Yunus Nia and
Gibran have described a mechanism by
which microglia can take up living
neurons if they don't present so-called
don't not eat me signals on their
surface
now what is the time course of this
phenomenon when we leave from various
papers and pet evidence that beta
amyloid deposition could start as early
as two to three decades before the
occurrence of first clinical symptoms
then this neural degeneration mechanism
is actually a way before the patient
would come to clinic reporting short
term memory deficits in a phase which we
call mad cognitive impairment or info ad
but nevertheless knowing that the
amyloid deposition is such a strong
danger associated molecular pattern that
would mean that all the other mechanisms
thereafter are taking place in the
presence of information now this comes
on the background of various are s snip
polymorphisms which are coding for genes
that are important for either synaptic
function or innate immune signaling and
off the latter tram to CD 33 pin one and
others are prominent examples but also a
plea for has an impact on microglia
function and even prisoner limbs may
take part with some of their substrates
and to Michael Gao phagocytic clearance
of beta amyloid now next to this genetic
background which certainly will
influence the degree of innate immune
activity and capability our lifestyle
factors may do the same and here you can
see that Emunah senescence during aging
is a is certainly a strong risk factor
directly related to a dysfunctional
immune activation we know that systemic
infections can be a trigger or a motor
for cognitive decline
midlife obesity in young man between
forty to forty five years is a risk
factor that increases the risk for
Alzheimer's disease up to four fold to
thirty years later and fat mass is just
a constant source for cytokines as a
certain percentage of this masses
activated macrophages
perdón titus seems to be a contributing
factor sedentary lifestyle is an immune
compromised and brain trauma is probably
the most direct induction of a brain
inflammation all these factors here
share increased levels of the release of
immune factors and immune activation and
may be therefore a risk factor now
middle of obesity is one of the named
factors this is an example where you can
titrate your risk to develop Alzheimer's
disease thirty years later by your
sagittal abdominal diameter and BMI and
you can see this goes up to four fold
the conclusion of that work is that
midlife obesity increases the risk to
develop dementia and AD independently
from type 2 diabetes or any
cardiovascular disease this work by
Jackie vicina published in JAMA in 2010
shows that people who had moderate to
severe septicemia event would have a
high likelihood to present with
cognitive impairment thereafter and
probably develop dementia and after this
inflammatory event and it's in fact as
something which we see in the daily
clinical routine very often that people
would present after a strong pneumonia
or another type of
make inflammatory event with cognitive
decline and accelerated
neurodegeneration now there were a lot
of clinical studies or epidemiological
observations which would indicate that
for example the intake of nonsteroidal
and his laboratory drugs would be
protective or at least reduce the risk
and delay the onset for Alzheimer's
disease one of these studies was
published by intervals and copulate and
colleagues in the New England Journal of
Medicine and to 2001 and showed that the
long-term medication with dicks panic
ibuprofen in the medicine or naproxen
would effectively reduce the individual
risk to develop Alzheimer's disease
there's a lot of trials which have been
brought evidence together which points
into a similar direction but
nevertheless none of the acute treatment
studies with 80 patients have brought
any positive result so far so there's a
problem and maybe we have to rethink why
the anti-inflammatory treatment
therapies which we have tested so far
were not effective so what could be the
problems first of all we have to think
how was this inflammatory activation
coming along in the brain is this a
linear development is this an asymptotic
development or an exponential
development and I suggest that this none
of any of those I believe inflammation
may run in waves like in a normal skin
wound where inflammation is defending
our body from bacterial invasion there
is an increase there's swelling there is
redness
there is pain and at a certain stage
resolution so probably what we see in
the ad brain that we have an early
inflammatory
rice being caused by a video oligomers
fibrils aberrant RNA or misfolded
proteins and peptides which in this
initially may compromise clearance start
to induce proliferation of michael via
and decrease trophic factors supply then
we have the release of further danger
associated molecular parents such as
chroma guanine a from neurons MRP
fourteen heat shock proteins which may
contribute to the aforementioned
mechanisms but also lead to neuron
dysfunction and damage anonymously the
loss of neurons is going to change the
neurotransmitter levels and we know that
various neurotransmitters are actually
guiding or regulating microgram
activation proliferation and senescence
and so fundamental changes of
neurotransmitter profiles may impact on
another kind of inflammatory wave under
those degenerative circumstances
now it's important to note that the time
point of Investigation will influence
the nature quantity and quality of
inflammatory signals detected and
thereby also leads to a biased
identification of possible therapeutic
targets you know one could probably hit
a target at its peak or add the decline
or in the middle of it and the
interpretation will be very different so
all the longitudinal data we are still
missing need to be generated and we need
to be very careful with cross-sectional
analyzers which we very much rely on to
date another confound with micro glial
activation is that we have quite
different
microglia depending which brain region
we are looking at these are paper by
Robert and colleagues from 2016 where
transcriptome differences were shown
between my cobra isolated from the
cerebellum the stratum the cortex or the
hippocampus so what could be the basis
of this difference and again very
interesting review article by Jennifer
Pocock and Homewood captain man
published in tins at a time ago shows
how many neurotransmitter receptors
actually carried by my cochlear cells
and this is an example of how for
example no adrenaline through adrenal
sceptre ligation can regulate microglia
reaction towards amyloid beta we see a
ribbon of has protection SA and under
control ABT simulation or co-stimulation
with no benefit conditions and it
becomes quite clear that an open-air and
suppresses the activation of these
microglia cells by a be that one to
forty two it does not only suppress the
inflammation it also increases the
interest and the micropyle clearance
capacity in the whole
brain of mice this is an experiment
shown by two photon laser scanning
microscopy where Michael D s sells
around a little everyday deposit in
noble nephron intact conditions while
under these before which depletes no
benefit from the brain you can see that
at a very tiny black site microbial
cells assemble at time point zero six
weeks after this plaque has grown
substantially and there's no michael
glial cells
who which would try to limit this or
take amyloid beta and down this actually
can be rescued by treating these animals
with l3 adopts which is a dryer wrecked
nor adrenaline precursor in converted by
dopa decarboxylase and able to rise
cortical and limbic system levels of no
penetrant after these before treatment
now next to this probably changed levels
of microglia guidance and in regulation
through neurotransmitters microglia
cells undergo cell death and
proliferation in a PPP is one mouse
models and ad patient brain as indicated
here so on the right side this schematic
shows an increase in cortical and hyper
temple microglia proliferation over time
and this can be found in the brains of
patients back so interestingly we have
always believed that michael Chiesa
which would encounter beta-amyloid
peptide would probably show an acute
inflammatory reaction and turn into a
chronic active microglia cell the
question is if this is a correct model
and I want to suggest that we have to
think about
microglia population change by
accelerated proliferation of microbial
cells which are populating our brain
very early inform this very nice lattice
encounter and early amyloid be they
deposit some of them will undergo death
some of them will undergo proliferation
and activation or surrounding this
amyloid beta deposit and as time - this
many different generations of microbial
cells may may actually arise and this
would mean that we are not going with
one microglia population but with more
this is one of many datasets shown over
one beer do you incorporating cells
enemy toxic so for positive amyloid beta
pack now over time when we start with
surveying and clearing microglia cells
over time under neurodegenerative
conditions we could have multiple
generations of microglia cells which
would then become harder to target
because the cells would proliferate into
such an inflammatory environment
probably acquire functions and and
actions way different from those which
have originally populated the brain now
there are a lot of studies on Moran
microglia so we wanted in our group to
focus on functional signalling pathways
which are really important to human
microglia and this paper by Bart Eggman
and Eric Boudica has nicely combined
four different data sets to generate
what they call a human micro gear
co-signature and what you see right in
the center of this is Tory
center of this other not like receptors
and the inflammasome as well as their
products are one beta and I'll 18 now
the nav inflammasome in the brains of
mice and any patients is restricted to
microbial cells it's highly controlled
it requires step of transcriptional
activation ligation of a colleg receptor
or cytokine receptor which then induces
the generation of transcription factors
and cytokines and chemokines also the
auto inhibited nab 3 and this is
followed by next step of post
transcriptional activation various steps
that license the activation after nav
inflammasome information of an aspect
which then has the active caspase-1
which is able to convert pro forms of
alameda la tène and gizumon to either
the activists remain p10 that forms the
poor or the active cytokines including
all 18 in alameda first thing we did was
we analyzed whether this mechanism was
actually found in human ad and here you
can see Michael vs cell containing and
ask speck and green more quantitative
way we assess the activation of the
inflammasome by immunoblotting for pro
and please caspase-1 and if we do so in
brain samples from aged men on demented
controls and 80 cases you will see that
there is a strong increase increase
caspase-1 signal in ad patient brains
and this phenomenon is not restricted to
80 cases can also be found in patients
which
suffer from MCI so the pre-staged of our
summers disease now importantly the
pathway Astana inflammasome activation
is highly conserved between Mouse and
men and pike card also called ask
Alameda caspase-1 and now Express mostly
by my cochlea and macrophages in both
pcs
used the a PPP is one transgenic mouse
model because this is an hour of you
moran model that is ideal to investigate
the consequences of innate immune
activation can see that these green
amyloid deposits here are massively
surrounded by red microglia cells in
this model using this a PPP is one mouse
model we then crossed not knockout
animals into it and one of the important
findings was that while the a PPP is one
animals were characterized by reduced
traffic spectra secretion knots to
expression in our one secretion of
microbial cells in this case on an mRNA
level here we found that this was all
converted by the presence of now
knockout animal background so instead
microglia from a PPP is one that
knockout mice showed increased levels of
Arjun is one is one and al four
and most importantly they also showed a
strong increase in IDE and IDE is one of
the key enzymes of XSL amyloid-beta
degradation now when we looked and under
high magnification to amyloid-beta
deposits we found that it in ATP peas on
transgenic mice the microbial cells
would surround the plaques but would not
very much interact with them and seem to
be paralyzed while in the case of the a
PPP's wall knob deficient animals the
microglial cells were really taking the
amyloid beta apart and sending lassos
into the plaque which were filled with
beta amyloid indicating active
phagocytic clearance so in order to
possess this possible clearance
mechanism we developed a say which
allowed us to quantify micro Glau
phagocytic uptake of beta amyloid and we
used methoxy before injection waited for
three hours expanded the brain isolated
the Mack michael chiha and hacks them
for the matrix EXO for now what we found
was that in contrast to ATP ps1 AP
people on nap
knockout mice showed a much higher
amount of maitake EXO for containing CD
eleven be positive my cochlea cells and
there was over a number of eight animals
to fold increase in phagocytic clearance
cells were then isolated and analyzed
that we found that we can overlay the
toxic so for with another amyloid beta
specific antibody IC 16 within the CD 11
be positive immune cells showing them
over the time of three hours these cells
in fact had taken on that amount of
amyloid beta
this increased clearance in response to
an ALP deficiency reduced the hyper
Campbell frontal cortical and modal
cortical amyloid beta by about 70 to 80
percent and this result was also
confirmed by Eliza measurements so in
order to assess a spatial navigation
memory we are using the so called Morris
water maze test where animals follow
cues in a water bath seeking a hidden
platform as you can see in this little
movie and after a while the mouse will
find the platform the parameters we test
are actually the time to platform which
is called latency as well as the
distance the animal are swimming before
they actually sit on the platform as you
can see now so this is being analyzed at
eight consecutive days and in this
experiment you see that while 7l
decision animals very quickly learn the
task and then they consolidate that
information while I TPP is one animals
in red don't learn much over these eight
days a DPP's one knock on animals were
almost as good despite there were 18
months of age and so they were all most
performing as good as the one tap on a
knockout mice on day nine we perform a
probe trial so the platform is being
removed and you can see then whether the
animals have spent time in the first
quadrant
remembering that the platform had been
there and what you see on the right side
is that while time and now positioned
animals do so quite good the a P P P is
one Mouse has a more random search
strategy at day nine while the a P P P
is one that decision animals actually
very much restricting their time to
quadrant
so the next interest we had were to
analyze whether innate immunity would
actually contribute to disease
progression because we all know that
amyloid pathology spreads within the
brain area and from one brain area to
another and the brain is not destructed
in the week or a month but it takes
several years to take it down and so the
current model of spread of pathology
implies that fragmentation of fibro is
then followed by a nucleation and growth
and once fiber has a certain length it
would fragment again and would represent
a new nucleus so following this we asked
whether innate immunity would contribute
to disease progression and spreading off
pathology now we did so because in a
collaboration with threatened Leuven in
Belgium we very early observed that when
we compare a PPV 7 1 7 I so-called
London mutation single transgenic mice
we don't observe any XSL and morbidity
position at 3 months but we already see
focal microglia and focal acidly
activation and interestingly this
microglia activation was characterized
by our 1 beta positivity
so the microbial cells were here
positive for a factor which we connected
to the activation of the NAB lamisil and
asks back formation so microglial cells
in fact let me get over activated and
exposed to pro-inflammatory cytokines
will undergo a so-called para product
cell death and release the asks
and in fact in 80 patient brains as well
as in a PPP is one transgenic mouse
brains we can see ask specs within
microbial cells but also in the XSL of
space so we learned to identify and
track these asked specs in cell culture
and actually induce micrograph Arab
ptosis by MPs priming and exposure to
nitrogen or ATP and then it was we were
aiming and showing that beta amyloid
would be a fantastic inducer of Michael
Tabb ptosis and we kind of failed here
what we found is that as soon as an ask
spec would release be released by
Michael TSL the beta-amyloid peptide
would be very quickly bind to this ask
spec and you will see in this little
video that my Michael be ourselves which
release and ask back show the direct
binding of the red labeled amyloid beta
to the spec play video
we next looked at this on an e/m level
and you can see here amyloid beta 1 2 42
alone asked alone and hopefully you
would agree that amyloid beta and asked
them kind of very tightly bound into the
Congo Batian experiment that lead to the
hypothesis that once Michael VSL would
undergo activation inflammasome
formation and ultimately Michael Clouse
parabiosis the released asks back could
interact with the beta amyloid peptides
and represent matrix which would be the
initial step in clackety position
and to assess this we utilize the tail
flame in t fluorescence si in green you
can see the aggregation curve of my data
in the absence of any ask and then it
this shows the conversion from the
monomer to the aggregate over time and
it's easy to see that adding increasing
concentrations of aspects to this causes
a very strong shift to the left
indicating classical cross feeding
looking at the same or a similar
experiment rebound by immunoblot you can
see that after 24 hours in the absence
of any ask there's hardly oligomers and
on this queue a bigger fiber of
formation while under increasing
concentration there's strong formation
of fibrils and a B de oligomers this is
an experiment which used amyloid beta 1
240 and it looks very much the same for
amyloid beta 1 2 42 now in another
experiment we used close limitation and
say we had three different conditions a
more data 40 or 42 alone and the
presence of a score asked alone over six
hours and what you see is that
everything starts in the supernatant
attempt on zero and after six hours the
ask has dragged the entire amyloid
peptides in a almost artificial Calot or
black structure now real tracks show
binding of IPS to amyloid beta in an age
dependent manner in mice at 8 and 12
months when we look to the black
histology we found that ask actually
sits in the center of the beta amyloid
plaque and the 60 10 positive amyloid
beta
is surrounding this poor a little like
in the movie I've just shown you so that
would not yet indicate that the presence
of the asks back is the start of the
black deposit and in order to test this
hypothesis we employed a model which has
been nicely introduced by Matias you can
Larry Walker and summarize in stellar
nature article in 2013 so the basic
principle of this experiment is to
compare solvent control and a PPP is one
lies it injection in up in the hyper
campy of opposing brain hemispheres and
to wait a certain time period to read
out the spread of abdi pathology and
interestingly a synthetic a beta is
almost not sitting in this model and
suggesting that amyloid beta itself may
be different or there may be one or
further endogenous Co factors which are
responsible for this observation now
this is a this experiment shows you the
comparison between what a brain lives
say to a TPP's one lies it injection in
an AP PPS one mouse model and we
actually verify the results published by
Matias yuca and Melanie Maya lumen into
8 and the open to the full bar shows a
two-fold increase in area and the number
of ABA plaques in the analyzers of
fibrils and oligomers you see a strong
increase total ABA is dramatically
increased no effect on ATP processing or
a PP itself now as a comparison we
looked at brain material from non
injected minds and here you can see that
one type of mouse brain and I said
injection is not having a gradient so
the none injected animal
principal Presley the same as the
wildtype lies it receiving mouse brain
shows and the next step was to do this
experiment in the absence of asked and
this took the entire induction or
increase in area and a bida deposit
number away but more importantly it
prevented the formation of oligomers and
fibrils and did not increase total
amyloid-beta
- this experiment suggests that at least
in this model the presence of ask is
required to induce the spreading of a be
damned pathology
now what about humans when we IP for ask
and we blood for amyloid beta we found a
bead a bound asked only in the brains of
80 cases but not in age matched controls
more interestingly when we splitted the
fluffy fiber compartment from the core
of the planet and analyzed the frames of
MCI cases we also already found a
colocalization of asking a big data in
the core of MCI plaques were the only
difference to altima cases was that
there was more a beta in the fiber
compartment now looking at these plaques
most of them show an ask positive red
core and six again green material
surrounding it again supporting the view
that the early innate immune activation
and the Peripatetic relief release of
aspects could be one dimension which is
important to black t position now is
this a current finding I don't believe
so because in this picture from a
frontal cortex of an eighty case where
we stained for a scan IB de you see a
lot of em ghost microglia which have
undergone para product death you see
released as specs all over but they
didn't inlet on the right side which is
taken from a publication by al-assad
cement hands no sir in 1911 shows you
that you can see all these destructed my
cochlea already in their publication so
I think they were quite aware of
the microglia pathology which takes
place in this disorder now what about
Tao
one of the interesting questions along
was whether Tao next to a betta would
also be able to induce now inflammasome
activation and in order to test this we
used brain line States throughout our 22
animals which were provided kindly by
look away from little in northern France
dress and you can see that there's a
minor increase in L 1 beta release by
microglia cells which are exposed to
tell 22 brains as content as compared to
all type of brains so encouraged by this
experiment we actually went on and used
cow monomers oligomers and fibrils for
now inflammasome induction and here you
can see by readout of allenby de
production that monomers and oligomers
were quite efficiently inducing their
one beta release and less so hybrids in
all cases however this was dependent on
the presence of the noun 3 inflammasome
this is further supported by the
analyzes of priests caspase-1 in this
capillary western blot where you see
that more tamanho Merson oligomers and
use a strong caspase-1 cleavage while
fibrils
are by far not as efficient in doing so
so the animal model actually was
carrying mutations from patients
families suffering from frontotemporal
dementia so we set out to test whether
fish brain samples from those patients
would show an increase in caspase-1
cleavage and they do so FTD obviously is
characterized by a very strong induction
often out in summer so
it also shows strong increases and the
p17 band of album biga so that we are
sure that this system is generating this
key cytokine in the brains of FTD
patients
now it's always good to know that your
mouse model in this case the tower 22
animals mirrors key elements of the
human disease and you can see that
neuronal pathology especially
neurofibrillary tangles formation is
displayed quite nicely and in the animal
model generated by look way in his group
these animals also show caspase-1
cleavage and a one bigger production
depending on the presence of the now in
some cell
using these mice and analyzing their
brains with a nano string
neuroinflammation panel we found that in
our hands the first on first sight the
PCA analyzes would cluster for H and not
so much for being a towel
transgenic which just on suicide was
disappointing but by looking more closer
to these results we actually found that
what we detect what we detected was the
induction of a senescence associated
secretory profile or it's induces along
with various inflammatory mediators
now that encouraged us to cross the Tao
22 mice and now borass MacLeod
animals and so we waited for eight
months to read this out by 88 mythology
and you can see that asthma cows and
more so that without protection and
quantifying a larger number of mice
showed that this was for real and in
particular now knock out would be
protective for this type of pathological
doubt change in the tail 22 - well but
because it's unlikely that one pathway
is important for both the ABA as well as
the tau pathology we repeated this
experiment waiting a little longer in
the hope that the phenomenon would faint
out but it didn't do so after 11 months
the protection was even stronger in the
ask and now a knockout how 22 mice as
compared to tell 22 animals so we had to
come up with an explanation and as a
regular as a recapitulate tau
phosphorylation is guided by various
phosphokinase is opposed by one or more
phosphatases and if the activation force
kinase is is stronger than the
phosphatase activity this leads to
neural early no durability angle
formation and neuronal destruction so we
tested this in the brains we had and
what we found was that we actually
reduce the amount of inactive PP to a
well at the same time reducing active
campaign is to alpha and to a lesser
extent G's k3b de
now importantly we were able to show
that the modulation of cam kinase to
alpha is critical for the observed
protection because it's target Tao
phosphorylation at 7 406 strongly
reduced Intel 22 - when they were now
before asked decisions so ultimately we
wanted to bring this on a cell culture
level in order to delineate the involved
pathway and what you can see here is
that microbial cells which have been
generated from wild-type now contrast
knockout can be stimulated by certain
protocol LPS and ATP - induced
inflammasome then we take the
conditional media transfer them on
primary hypercam poll neurons and
analyze those at 24 hours so in this
experiment we found that inflammation
strongly induces phospho cam kinase
alpha which is depending on the presence
of asked and now
while congregation of hippocampal
neurons would be interleukin one
receptor antagonist would strongly
reduce this observation as the use of an
Eric 4 inhibitor or a Mac one 2
inhibitor
so furthermore we found that tell five
and paired helical filaments are
strongly induced by and this
inflammatory stimulus and reduced in the
absence of a scan out knock out on a
behavioral read out in these animals do
not show learning defense so they over
the eight days of learning the animals
are indistinguishable from wild-type or
ask on a pop out but at day nine when we
test with a probe trial the memory we
can see that while wild-type asked on
our god animals spend way more time in
the quadrant where the platform had been
located the 10/22 animals seem not to
remember and have random search strategy
but when cross into ask or now block out
they regain this function and the better
groups are almost as good as the animals
which do not carry at our 22 transgene
so the ultimate question was how to get
from a be deposits to neurofibrillary
tangles and whether innate immune
activation in particular now exam
selectivity would contribute to a media
associated and secondary tell pathology
and to address this we used a model
introduced by your guts when he was
working in the lab with Hagen edge and
this paper has been published in science
into a1 I what Jung did was he compared
a P P lies aid injection with solvent
control and Intel 22 miles with it the
same to test for spread of tau pathology
which in hack can be seen in the first
two panels while up to eighty PBS one
injections o88 staining readouts this is
the read against the the red bar in one
tab versus the red bar and a PPP is one
brain homogenate receiving hemisphere
however when we do this in astronomical
mice this increase is completely gone
indicating that between the position of
amyloid beta and the spreading of tau
pathology inflammation that could be an
important contributing factor so in
summary we come up with a model where
Michael dear cells aren't undergoing
examine some activation in response to
pattern recognition ligation they form a
gas turbine deep or and release Alameda
and r18 these mediators especially our
media seem to bind to the r-1 receptor
in using a mighty 88 mek one two
dependent can kinase phosphorylates
which then phosphorylates the respective
sides and the Tau leading compared
helical filum information and
neurofibrillary tangles
and with this I would like to summarize
I hope I could convince you that bigger
sheet structured amyloids are known
dangerous signal to myeloid cells
including microglia during waves of
prone engine cemetery changes several
other dams or may arise in any patient
brain and maybe also in other
degenerative diseases of the brain then
albums Amazon pathway is highly
conserved between species and strongly
increased in brains of 80 patients
experimentally in more than 80 models
now the ambition is protective aspects
are released by microglia Parab ptosis
and they bind to a beader peptides and
increase their propensity to aggregate a
concentration and time dependent manner
in vitro and in vivo and an amp 3
inflammation knockout reduced how
pathology in tout ready to mice this
effect is likely to be mediated through
the modulation of tau kinases and the
phosphatase PB to a and ultimately I
would like to thank all the people in my
group and our great collaborators and of
course the people who have paid for this
work thank you for your attention